Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, everybody. We have
what what an eventful night we had last night.
We have our first series of a really important
results for the 2022 midterms. We had a number
of different primaries yesterday. Some of the
results are absolutely delightful and some of
the results are absolutely horrifying. It really
runs the full gamut. And we're going to get to
all of it. Two races that we were following very
closely in Pennsylvania, the Senate race, why the
Senate race in Pennsylvania, the Senate race in
Pennsylvania could decide whether Democrats or
Republicans ultimately control the Senate starting
in January of 2023. And if it comes down to
Pennsylvania, on the one hand, we want to know who
is the Republican nominee going to be. And on the
other hand, we also are following whether Trump's
endorsements continue to have value. And Mehmet Oz
was the Trump endorsed candidate in the Republican
Pennsylvania Senate primary. Also, delightfully,
I was gleefully seeing the results yesterday
that Trumpist Congressman Madison Cawthorn
lost his primary. He's out. He's been in office
16 months and he has already lost the primary. And
he is going, bye bye. So let's look at this one by
one, starting with North Carolina's 11th District.
Chuck Edwards, a current Republican state senator
in North Carolina, has defeated the incumbent,
Madison Cawthorn. Now, it was close. Edwards
coming in with just over 33% of the vote. Cawthorn
losing with just under 32% of the vote. But
nobody saying it's so close, we need a recount.
For now. Nobody's talking about fraud. In
fact, Madison Cawthorn is actually saying
that establishment forces in the Republican Party
turned against him because he would criticize
those who needed criticism and all of this stuff,
which we will get to. But this is absolutely
fantastic news and we're going to talk about that
more in a moment. I'm on the Pennsylvania side,
starting with the Democratic primary, John
Fetterman almost literally from an operating room,
easily winning the primary. John Fetterman, as
we talked about on the bonus show yesterday,
had a stroke over the weekend, ended up needing
to have a pacemaker with defibrillator installed
via surgery yesterday. He's doing well. He easily
won. The reports are he will make a full recovery
and will be strongly back on the campaign
trail. Fetterman will be facing the winner
of the Republican primary. And as of this moment
when we're taping today's show, we don't know who
that is. All night, Trump endorsed Republican
Mehmet Oz was losing, losing to Dave McCormick.
And as the night went on, Oz chipped away,
chipped away, chipped away at the advantage
that McCormick had. And by the end of the night,
by this morning, with 95% of the vote counted,
Mehmet Oz is ahead by only 2500 votes. That's
0.2% of the vote. As a just as a reminder,
in Pennsylvania, if the margin of victory is
one half of 1% or less, it triggers an automatic
recount. These numbers aren't final. But the
point is, if the numbers end up being this close,
there will be an automatic recount. And we're off
to the races again and we will see ultimately what
the results of that are. But we don't yet know
because they are still counting ballots. Now,
we're going to talk about Pennsylvania governor
in a separate segment. It's a very important
race and it deserves its own time, but we will
get to that in a moment. So Madison Cawthorn
tweeting a concession, a quote, Congratulations to
Chuck Edwards on securing the nomination. Tonight,
it's time for the 11th District Republicans
to rally behind the Republican ticket
to defeat the Democrats November nominee.
This November, Cawthorn did praise Trump
when conceding. Take a look at this clip.
Speaker 2: Oh, you know what is the thing
that I love about President Trump is that when
you get your back pushed up against the wall,
I found that most people in politics, if it's not
politically expedient to them, they'll turn your
back on you in a heartbeat. But no matter what
you are facing, when Donald Trump has your back,
he has your back to the end. And that is why.
Speaker 1: I don't know that I really agree with
that. I mean, this was politically expedient for
Trump to endorse Cawthorn. At the end of the day,
the guy running against Cawthorn isn't like a
wild Trumpist and Cawthorn is a wild Trumpist,
so that's the political expediency. Just
before conceding, Cawthorn did weigh in
on the leaks of his pictures and videos and all
of this stuff. He says it's a coordinated strike
from within the Republican Party to take him down.
Speaker 3: Several photos and videos of you
circulating on. On social media recently.
What can you say to those constituents who
may have lost some confidence in you and
and are looking for some other kind of leadership?
Speaker 2: You know what? I'll tell you? There's
been a coordinated strike carried out by really
trying to hold establish a wing of our party.
And I think it's it's a losing mentality. They
realize the direction the country is going in,
the direction that the population is going in.
And if they want to be able to pay off people
from my past, try and bring up old pictures
of things that happened years and years ago.
I feel free to let them do that. I think the
American people will see the right.
Speaker 1: Well, whatever. I mean,
listen, he's right. It was very clear that
the Republican Party establishment decided
we don't want Madison Cawthorn to remain in the
House of Representatives. Now, his framing is
it won't matter because the country is going in
his direction. He lost the primary. He is out.
And that's an absolutely fantastic thing. Voters
have, in a sense, sent Madison back to his room to
think about what he did. Katherine's loss is also
a loss for Trump. Trump went on troth central. He
he calls it troth central, as you might remember,
trope central. It's actually called truth social.
Trump went on truth and endorsed Cawthorn two
nights ago, and this one did not go Trump's way.
So that is a loss for Trump. Now, meanwhile, this
is just bizarre. At his event last night, Mehmet
Oz thanked Fox News propagandist Sean HANNITY.
Speaker 2: If you proud, I want to thank
Sean HANNITY.
Unidentified:
Sean's like a brother to me.
Speaker 2: When Sean punches through something,
he really punches through it. He understands
exactly how to make a difference. And he's
been doing that this entire campaign, much of
it behind the scenes, right. Giving me advice,
a late night conversations. Again, the kinds
of things that true friends do for each other.
Speaker 1: In another era in the
American political media landscape.
It would be outrageous to hear that an on
air host on one of the major networks was not
only openly supporting one of the candidates in a
primary, but behind the scenes giving them advice
and pep talks. At one point that would have been
that would have been seen as inappropriate. No,
no, no. Listen, you have an on air persona, and it
wouldn't it's not right for you to be advising a
candidate in this way without it being really
what you're doing officially, your audience,
you're doing one thing and then you're
doing another thing behind the scenes,
and you're attacking Oz's opponent on
air without disclosing that you have
this sort of informal adviser. To the extent
we know it's informal advisory relationship,
at one point that would have been outrageous.
Now we just kind of shrug and go, Yeah, HANNITY
picked the candidate and was helping Mehmet Oz.
And then on the other hand, Dave McCormick, who
we still don't know whether it will be Oz or
McCormick almost in a in a in a tie at this point,
2500 votes separating them. This you have to see
beyond parody. McCormick now says we might still
win because of mail in ballots, which, of course,
the whole line from the Republican Party has been
mail in ballots are bad. Mail in ballots are
fraud. And now McCormick is saying, don't worry,
we've still got the mail in ballots
coming. Now we're going to get.
Speaker 2: We're going to win this campaign.
Unidentified: We're going to win this camp.
Speaker 2: And and tomorrow, right
now, we have tens of thousands
of mail in ballots not being counted that are
going to need to be counted beginning tomorrow.
And and so that's unfortunate. We're not going
to have resolution tonight, but we can see the
path ahead. We can see victory ahead.
Speaker 1: And don't worry, guys,
the mail in ballots my party has attacked for
the last two years are what ultimately will save
us. And this is normal for the right, whatever
fits the narrative of the current 5 minutes they
go with. So those are some races. Great to see
Madison Cawthorn defeated. That's bad for Trump.